[Music]
my name is Marcus and I'm a senior data
scientist at Scout 24 Scout 24 operates
two Dutch marketplaces in Germany in
other European countries one is focused
on real estate and the other one on
mobility today I want to talk about my
latest project for autoscout24 and it's
really all about going from a search
entry that is dominated by radio buttons
and drop-down menus to this a simple
text box now a couple of weeks ago I
mentioned to my dad that we're now live
with a new feature and he cheekily
commented that Google seems to have
already build something similar and he's
right of course text search is nothing
new these days so what makes this an
interesting problem the thing is if
you're looking to buy a car keyword
search is not good enough we have more
than 2 million listings across Europe
one outers card and if you want to bring
that down to a smaller number so that
you can start contacting the sellers you
need to filter yet my location price
mileage or equipments makes and models
ultimately this is a structured search
problem so our goal with this feature is
really to provide an alternative search
entry so that our you to think about
filters ideally it again
looking for and we met it to the
corresponding filters and keywords so
let's look at a query to see what kind
of compiled components we would like to
extract howdy
r6 performance panorama 2018 howdy is a
make our six is a model performance is a
specific version of that model panoramas
and equipment and 2018 is a first
registration so here we have a user who
looks for a specific combination of a
make model with one specific version a
panorama roof and built from 2018
onwards and ideally when we show such an
input to a system we would like the
system to set three filters one keyword
in one range clearing so from a machine
learning perspective I decided to
approach this as a sequence a sequence
problem and in sequence the sequence
learning is quite something amazing I
have to say it's a very generic
framework essentially that allows you to
go from a variable like tanks input
sequence to a verbal language output
sequence so you train a model to map
from an input to an output and typically
this is done using an encoder decoder
architecture so you have an encoder that
looks at the inputs and produces
embeddings and you have a decoder that
looks at the embeddings from the encoder
and produces an output sequence and for
a very long time they're the go-to
method when it comes to sequence of
sequence burning was recurrent neural
networks and recurrent neural networks
essentially process the input one
position at a time and produce an
embedding that summarizes all the
information of the previous tones so
return neural networks are inherently
sequential and that makes them slow you
have to operate over the input in
sequence in 2017 and I'm sure most of
you have heard about this Google
presented an alternative like a
next-generation way to do sequence of
sequence and they call it the
transformer the transformer architecture
doesn't need recurrence anymore
so with the transformer you can attend
to all the inputs at once and that makes
training very fast of course the key
thing when you want to understand
language is context the meaning of a
word depends on the context and so the
embedding of a word should also depend
on that context with a recurrent neural
network you already incorporate context
because the single state that you
compute contains the information of the
entire sequence what the transformer is
doing it's using something called self
attention in self attention allows
transformer to look at the surrounding
words in the context and determine to
which extent they are relevant for the
current word and this also is possible
to do in in parallel so the transform is
very very fast and ever since it has
been introduced it's really at the
bottom of all the recent breakthroughs
in natural language processing basically
every time you read something about a
state-of-the-art results chances are
very good that the transformer sits at
the bottom it's at the core of Google's
bird it also sits at the core of open my
eyes DBT to the model that was deemed
too dangerous to release for quite a
while probably read about this and so my
thinking was maybe I can use this these
breakthroughs this very powerful method
to go from one sequence to another
sequence and simply learn a mapping that
goes from natural language to a
structured search theory
what makes this appealing is
traditionally when you do letter
language processing you have a pipeline
you have several steps that operate on
the input you have maybe damnit ization
and then you move stop words when you
clean your input in some way when we use
these approaches we can simply feed in
inputs and outputs and the model worries
about the rest
so it's end-to-end learning it's similar
to what happened in image recognition so
in the beginning when computer vision
people would also construct filters to
extract features from images and this
would be hint hand-crafted filters and
then at some point on top they would
learn some simple classifier until 2012
and in 2012 what happened is they
started to learn end-to-end
so straight from the pixels to what
you're interested in and let the your
network worry about computing the
intermediate representations and in the
transformer or these end-to-end natural
language models they allow you to do
something similar so in successive steps
they refine the representation of words
always accounting for the context and
they've just proven to be very very
powerful so before I talk a little bit
more about the data the training and
also the deployment of this I want to
show you a couple of examples from the
live system so we live in up in all of
Germany for a couple of weeks now and on
the top left you see very simple clearly
a user trust typed in the name of the
model the system was smart enough to say
hey I've seen this before this is a Fiat
and do the corresponding theory for a
make and the model in the middle you see
an example for a query that also
contains the range restriction so users
only interested in cars before 1970 and
on the last panel you see a user that
didn't even specify a make or model he's
simply interested in red who pays note
between 1960 and 1980 so far this is all
queries that contain filters and range
queries but we also sometimes need
keywords so here on the Left we have a
very specific very likely done by user
who knows something about American
muscle cars he's looking for a very
specific engine size they know that in
cubic inches and this is information we
don't have available for most of our
listings but we make it searchable if
it's part of the title of the listing so
here the system was smart enough to say
hey this is a reasonable thing to
describe a listing I'm just going to put
this into the version field and we were
able to find the listing using keyword
search the reason why this is really
cool is the system also has learned to
ignore certain things so it doesn't just
copy everything it does know about into
the version fields otherwise we would
have a lot of results to trust don't
give you any less
so the system has already learned to
ignore certain inputs for example if you
take us for google which happens people
type in the name of our competitors we
kindly ignore you there's also a lot of
stuff that doesn't have to do anything
with cars in which we still see it but
in this case it was able to realize this
makes sense as a keyword and this is
actually non-trivial like if you wanted
to build something like this from hand
it would actually be rather complicated
but with a sequence the sequence
approach you can just show the system
examples and it's just gonna learn to to
make these mappings by itself now in the
middle you see a combination of a filter
a keyword and the range query and on the
last panel you see a rather complex
query we don't see these a lot but it's
possible in principle you can search for
cars before 1980 with more than 200
horsepowers between 30 and 50 thousand
viewers so the last three examples I
wanted to show you illustrate what I
mean by context because the meaning of a
word really is highly dependent on
context and keep in mind for this system
2002 is just another word it's just
another input total so all three queries
containing BMW 2002 but they have
completely different meanings and the
system is able to extract that meaning
in the first panel we have a search for
a very specific BMW BMW 2002 in the
middle panel the user looks for BMWs
before the year 2002 so that's a range
theory for first registration and in the
last panel users looking for cars below
2000 years essentially once again the
system here looks at the context and is
able to update the representation of
2002 and then translated correspondingly
to a structured theory
now I want to give you some idea of the
variety we see in the real system cause
all the examples that I showed you were
simple in the sense that they didn't
contain any misspellings or any typos
now I did expect some type of a new in
life with the system but I was still
surprised at the sheer amount of typos
and this is just a fraction of we're
observing and these are three fairly
well-known makes and you see there's
like no end to to mint or two typos and
if you just think about how difficult it
would be to build a reg X that could
handle this input it just highlights how
cool it is that we now have systems that
can learn this end to end so as I
mentioned before our goal with the
system is really to have something that
is for bus that can ignore irrelevant
inputs that can handle type was and that
can handle informal language synonyms
and all these things but when you want
to train such a system you need data now
for me this was a problem because here
was with his idea to build something but
we never had a search functionality with
free text so I was lacking the input
data typically when you want to transfer
in when you want to train in your
machine translation model you need
what's known as a parallel corpus so you
have two files in each of the lines you
have one sentence there's a line to line
correspondence that say from English to
German and then the system can learn the
mapping in our case I didn't have the
input I didn't have natural language
queries all we had rest structured
queries millions of those so I was
thinking to myself if it would be
possible to generate some artificial
training data using simple rules
essentially back translating from in
structured query to one of many possible
variations of natural language and
that's what I did I just brought a
simple script generated a couple of
million training examples and trained a
model and then I put it in a little
flask web app and I shouted to the PM's
with program managers
and it's quite amazing when you are able
to it's not a core data science skill
but for me it has proven to be very
valuable when you're able to build
something and then show it to people you
can build a little demo can put it into
the hands of people and they can play
with it because despite the fact that
the model was only trained on very
simple artificial data and hasn't seen a
lot of variability it already performed
quite well and was actually already able
to generalize beyond the examples that
have shown it and so I got a green light
to go live and the idea here was build a
simple model based on this artificial
data and then go into production and
refine it using real user feedback
because if users not happy with the
answer that will be provide at least
some users are going to correct that
theory they're gonna resort to the
filters and they're gonna make a
correction then we can learn from that
correction and retrain the model and so
over time the model becomes better and
that's what we did so we went initially
live with just 10 percent of our users
like an April and that initial test was
unusual because we didn't try to gauge
the user engagement was not a normal AP
test we just did this to generate more
data for the model to learn from and
since then we have refined it a bunch of
times there's more and more data and a
few weeks ago we went live so now all
users in Germany can play with the
system all right so we have our idea we
have the data now we need to train
luckily we live in great times there's
amazing frameworks out there like pi
torch and tensorflow and I decided to
make use of a very specific library
called tensor two tensor which builds a
tensor flow
what makes tens of the tensor very
special is it's maintained by the folks
at Google brain and it's the same code
base that they use internally what this
means for you if you use it is that
within days of a new paper appearing on
archive the code is here you can play
with it sometimes the code appears
before the paper is written and then
there's little note in the code say
fried paper so this is very cool because
it allows someone like me was not being
paid to re-implement other people's
research and I'm I'm measured against
delivering value to the business it
allows me to stay at the cutting edge of
research in this field I just using what
what the kind folks at Google brain make
available and so you find all the all
the publications there and also many
more papers that Google researchers
didn't write themselves it's really
meant as a way to to start you on
reproducible research so it contains a
lot of standard data sets it contains a
lot of models and hyper parameters which
makes it very easy to really represent
guesswork that would be involved in
trying to replicate some paper it's not
you don't have this year and they even
test the implementations regularly
against regressions so you can be sure
if you wanna let's say you read and you
read one of those papers you want to
duplicate one of the results with this
library you can do it because it's
tested and it's very simple so he does
install it using pip and then all you
need to specify is the model for example
transform a problem for example English
to German a directory where your data
lives some hyper parameters and for the
defaults problems they already come with
the library and the last one is a
training directory
now if you now point 10 support to the
training directory it's very easy to
lock experiments and what you see here
are three different experiments I was
running on the top panel you see the
year training loss and also the
validation loss and all models have been
trained for exactly the same amount of
time so for the same number of epochs
but you see if you look at one time they
differ so some models take a lot more
wall time to actually train that's the
first thing that's interesting and on
the bottom there's a bunch of metrics
that show you the quality of the
generated output now in our case it's
different from natural language where
there's multiple ways to say the same
thing we really want the query to be
accurate so it can be executed and
return results so the middle middle
metric the accuracy proceed per sentence
or per sequence is the one I look at the
most but the key takeaway here is it
really very lucky that Google decided to
conduct their research in the open
weather with a brain team and you can
build on state-of-the-art results with
very little effort try different
architectures typically just a couple
lines of code that you need to change
and just see if it applies to your model
which may which it may not so sometimes
the latest greatest model is actually
not the best fit for your current
problem but this enables records
experimentation and you can quickly
iterate what's also very great is it's
just one line to export this into a
servable and that was one of the main
reasons I decided to use tensorflow
because the ecosystem around tender flow
is just amazing
it's I mean when you want to deploy
models to production it's way more than
just training you have things like data
pre-processing where you need to worry
about a consistency between the batch
processing you do and then online
solving you have things like checking
that your data doesn't drift over time
you need to validate your models before
you push them to production and all
these things are available in a another
framework provided by Google called tf-x
tens of our extended so let's talk a
little bit about the production
environment so as I mentioned before
initially I was just building little
demo a little HTML font and for people
to play with if you want to go to
production it's very important that the
thing scales now they can handle bursts
and spikes and traffic what's not so
great about flowers is it's synchronous
so that means it's blocking which is to
say the time that's the model is to
computing the response during that time
the API would be blocked it could not
accept any fresh server requests so for
this project I decided to use starlet
which is a completely asynchronous
framework what this means is the API
itself can continue to accept incoming
requests and just hand them over to a
second component and that second
component is the model serving component
and what's very nice here is for the
model serving component I can do request
fetching which is to say the second
component can wait for a couple of
milliseconds to gather all the requests
and then process them at once and that
makes it very efficient and that can
also handle spikes very very nicely and
also makes for good utilization of the
resources so this is really the last
thing I wanted to leave you with and
that's the component calls called tenza
for serving it's part of T of X and
basically what what happens so you train
your model on your problem and you're
happy with it
it's a one line command from tens up to
10 so to export that into a safe model
format and if you now run the template
of serving binary which is just just a
little C binary its production harden
code just by Google also internally has
been out there for a few years now you
can just point enter for serving at a
folder
and put your model inside that folder
then what ends of a serving does for you
it provides your house the rest in the
tree our CP API that you can talk to if
you're interested in performance then of
course you use tree our RPC and this is
also what we're doing here so the
front-end can continue to accept
requests tokenize as those with the
vocabulary that we used for to train the
model builds a little protobuf and then
talks to buy a trpc2 the model server
and then once the response is ready it
returns that two or twelve consumers
what's also really nice some attentional
serving is there's a model watch a
component so if you have a new model you
can just drop it in the folder and then
what the system will do it will answer
the current requests with the old model
and then it will switch over to the new
model so there's no need for you to
start your instances or new doctrines or
whatever so I think it's a very nice
piece of code and what it really allows
you to do is you you can very quickly
move from experimentation to production
also if you don't really have resources
from engineering available so it means
the data scientist I can build the model
I can deploy it to production and it
scales so that's very nice and it's all
because we have these nice tools and so
just to conclude I think I was faster
than I expected we wanted to build this
in the future that allows users to
quickly get into the search funnel
without having to worry about filters
and we approach this using a sequence of
sequence learning where we really enter
and learn the mapping from the input the
user types in typos and everything to
the corresponding output we trained to
use intensive flow more specifically the
tens of attempts a library and then use
sensor for serving two to serve this in
production and what we see so far from
user engagement the feature is well
received
now we see people now looking for all
police cars of fire trucks or BMWs from
the eighteen
like very specific things and also users
who don't quite know what they're
looking for they can just say about the
hybrid below 30 thousand euros so I
think it's a it's an interesting
alternative it with a very rigid search
entry that you normally have when you
just go down filters and just let make
model and then make it more and more
specific alright thank you thank you so
much for talk you mentioned that you
made training example in artificial way
how it was you or you have a large
database and with different combinations
of parameters like age of the car price
and so on you create large amount of
this combination and then use some tool
to make it like make natural natural
queries right yes somehow so I actually
didn't I could have also used your right
artificial combinations because we know
our taxonomy so could have just
generated all kinds of combinations but
I actually looked at ectric theories so
what we really see your users are
looking for so I observe the structure
here is already from where you take this
queries user queries oh in our locks
it's part of the URL essentially if you
look for a car already the old system
using elastic search it's all encoded in
the URL so I took the bunch of URLs that
I'll just observe users generating when
they search for cars then the words
wrote a simple script that map's that
back to to natural language and of
course I couldn't incorporate all the
variability because different people
would express themselves differently so
it was very limited meaning that in the
beginning of the system was a little bit
brittle so we're in the beginning when
you would show it an input it hasn't
seen before it would sometimes react
very very strangely and that's why it
was so important to retrain it and
refine it using for
they are and another little questions as
I understand you generate you you get
more data from user interactions right
so if you have some if user put some
query in your box and you provide him
some contact he select a specific car
then we think that it is connected to
the query yes this is the way yes so the
way it works the system provides an
output and if the users not happy with
the results of the system is not gonna
interact with the results straightaway
he's gonna resort back to the filters
it's gonna either is gonna try a new
query or it's gonna make a correction
using filters so this is not meant to
replace the existing filters it's just
an additional search entry in what we
see actually also happening as users
sometimes they just correct it so you
type something in system didn't
recognize that you can just correct that
and I learn from that correction so they
essentially yeah using our users to
teach the system more tricks yeah I see
thank you yeah I think you're quite a
similar question to the one before how
big was the difference between the
engineered faked input and the real user
input so what do you mean by difference
sorry what do you mean by difference um
how well could you predict the real the
real users typing in real natural
language sentences with your with your
way of doing it so initially the
capabilities of the system reflected my
own biases when I decided to write
simple rules to construct natural
language so only queries that we're very
similar to done the ones I construct
that could be answered the system did
generalize a little bit I think it's
similar to when you train on imagenet
and you show it an image it hasn't seen
before it also makes an educated guess
sometimes but if you wouldn't show it
completely different input it will just
freak out for example the system right
now just recently I've seen people copy
over entire URLs and I never trained it
to pass URLs and ignore HTTP WWN or
that's
stuff but the system just that does it
now and if if part of the URLs are
usable and so there's a make or model or
a year in there the system is gonna use
that it's gonna kick start your your
search in our platform and but I never
taught at that specifically initially
however it would have done something
stupid
hello thank you very much for the talk
so in the beginning you mentioned a few
aspects like filters and keywords but
what if a user gives something which is
not in that basic query like a red card
or something like that I mean red card
works cars just being ignore because
it's it's already implicit if you're on
our platform and Rattus being used as a
filter but you're right there are still
things I can't map so the restriction is
really what we can express in filters or
key words and my hope is actually that
this because the capabilities of the
underlying technology they're really
there's almost no limit to what these
things can learn so my hope is it's
gonna learn different languages next so
right now it's just live in Germany we
want to train it on Spanish and Italian
all these languages same system and
hopefully at some point that we also
learn to map things that don't have a
direct correspondence to a filter for
come for example sports car it's nothing
we have now a taxonomy but maybe at some
point because the user provided us with
us with this input it will translate a
sports car as a two-seater over 150
horsepower for example so that's going
to be very interesting to witness which
direction it takes thank you hi a
question is how do you structure results
for a category what would be the first
point for instance for red BMW so what
is the year would be the first for red
BMW do you boost somehow some attributes
of cars because it is important to show
very good first yes I can't insert the
car and how do you manage this yeah so I
think your question is really about the
search component itself and I'm not even
touching search so I'm just mapping from
natural language to structured search we
still process this with our existing
search stack which is elastic search so
I just go from freeform input
a structured theory and then the rest
happens using our existing such thing
hey hey did you manage to include the
location yes unless you in Spanish is
very well you know look for for Garson
year-to-date place yes so right now in
Germany you can provide a city name or a
zip code it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens when we put it live all
over Europe because then we're gonna
have cities that also correspond to the
names of certain cars then we need to
disambiguate and also zip zip codes look
very differently in different countries
so but the potential is there that the
model itself could easily learn that
just the question of time like this I
and so for the structured output just to
understand sue is it are you generating
someone I get chasing string or just the
URL where it's just a URL but I could
also output output Jason okay and then
in general like if you want to
incorporate basic to make sure that it
understands the entirety of your
taxonomy you would really just generate
more training examples from from what
you have in your yeah so my hope is that
now I can kind of rely less and less on
these artificial examples and just
that's already happening now we get life
live queries in a quantity that's large
enough to just train it on an actual
user input so the only extension I have
in mind is to teach the system to make
more fields so initially we started with
a subset of fields that could be mapped
to a structured query to extend that and
then of course to train it on different
languages hi hey I have a question you
said that you want to translate it like
you want to train also modern languages
will you train all the system right from
scratch or you will find a way to
translate what you already trained so
I'm very lucky I work with a great set
of engineers and also PMS who are
willing to experiment and I think they
may allow me to just put the German
version live in Spain for example right
because then it already works for make
model prices are going to work yours are
gonna work some things are not gonna
work like I don't know minister das meal
there's different ways to say below two
thousand euro for example depending on
the language but I think the system is
going to learn this very quickly so it
just needs to pick up I think the
different translations for equipments
maybe and then how to express more or
less and all these these little
quantifiers to understand the Clery
proper correctly but it's already going
to work I think well enough so people
can use it and then hopefully they make
some Corrections and I can learn from
that so do you and how do you evaluate
the correctness of this thing and like
do you track how it improves or worsens
over time yes that's a good question so
one thing is of course offline we can
just look at the metrics I just showed
you for example accuracy per sentence
tells me how often did it really exactly
match the query I was looking for online
we can look at different metrics like
user engagement like did we show user
something that we then ended up looking
at or clicking or even contacting the
seller so that's something we
incorporate and then is it like how much
possible is that the model which was
trained earlier somehow drifts from the
reality so probably it's not so bad as
it's really learned all the time right
it's it's quite possible because there's
new models introduced all the time and
yeah so every time a new car is
basically put into the world the model
needs to learn that this car exists but
yes by retraining it's not always going
to be perfectly up-to-date but I think
within a couple of days it will always
know about what's what's currently out
there
you
[Music]